مساء الخير السعوديه والتحالف العربي بصفه
عامه في اليمن في مازق حقيقي
ماذا الدكتور احمد يوسف استاذ العلوم
السياسيه الموق بانه الخيار العسكري لم
ينجح والخيار السياسي غير مطروح على الاقل
في المدى المنظور
والحقيقه اليمن مع الوقت لتصبح فيتنام
جديده
للسعوديه تحديدا في دول التحالف اثنين
القديمه ازمه بيتنا بالنسبه للامريكان
نذكر حضراتكم ان الامريكان دخلوا فيتنام
او تدخلوا في الصراع الداخلي المحلي في
فيتنام في الخمسينات اعتقد منهم ان المهمه
سهله مناصره الجنوب الموالي للغرب في
مقابل الشمال المدعوم من الاتحاد السوفيتي
والدول الشيوعيه لكن هذه المهمه يعني
استمرت لاكثر من عشرين سنه وادت الى مقتل
مئات الالوف من الاهالي و 2 والى مقتل نحو
ثمانيه وخمسين الف جندي امريكي هي اكبر
وصار عليهم في اي صراع سياسي اه في صراع
عسكري خطه الولايات المتحده
الحقيقه علشان فهم ليه اليمن للاسف بهذا
الاتجاه او في اتجاهها الى ان تكون فيتنام
جديده نفهم القصه من الاول السعوديه او
التحالف لما شن الحرب على الحوثيين في
مارس 2015 كان عنده اهداف محدده هذه
الاهداف لاعاده الشرعيه متمثله في حكومه
الرئيس هادي اللي كان اضطر الى مغادره
صنعاء تحت ضغط الهجوم الحوتي ثم الى عدم
ثم الى السعوديه الامر الثاني تقليم اظافر
الحوثيين وبالتالي احتواء النفوذ الايراني
لان السعوديه مصره على ان الحوثيين مجرد
ذراع
لايران في
اراضي ال يعني بعد مرور حوالي خمس سنوات
من بدء العمليات العسكريه هذه الاهداف لم
تتحقق شرعي اعاده ولا اي حكومه تستطيع ان
تمارس عملها بشكل طبيعي في ظل ما يجري على
اراضي اليمن من اضطرابات وحروب ولا تم
تقليم اظافر
الحوثيين وتحيه
قدرتهم العسكريه او حتى اكبرهم على دخول
المفاوضات
بالعكس الحوثيين انتقلوا من مواقع الدفاع
الى مواقع الحكومه واصبحوا شبه يوميا
بيهددوا السعوديه و بدو يبيعوها بضربات مش
على داخل الاراضي اليمنيه داخل العمق
السعودي
نحن وصلنا للوضع ننسى يعني السؤال اللي
بيسال طوال الوقت للدوله في السعوديه تملك
هذه القوات المسلحه القويه ولكن بالاسلحه
المتقدمه وكذلك حليفتها الامارات اللي
يسميها الامريكان اسفرت الصغيره بسبب
قوتها العسكريه
والتحالف كل على بعضهم اقليميا ودوليا حتى
هذه اللحظه عن تحقيق انتصار حازم على
ميليشيا صغيره الاجابه متعدده يعني لها
اسباب كثيره واحده منها انه التحالف ال ال
الاطراف الاساسيه الامارات والسعوديه
بينهم خلافات كثيره وهم ليسوا على قلب رجل
واحد يعني على الورق الاثنين بيدعم
والشرعيه والاثنين بيدعموا وحده الاراضي
اليمنيه والاثنين بيستهدف واعاده واحد وهو
الحرفيين وال من ورائهم الايرانيين لكن
على ارض الواقع كل بلد من البلدين عندها
اجنده مختلفه واحيانا ب تتضارب والامثله
كثيره و اعطيك مثلا واحد اختصارا للوقت
انه في الوقت اللي بنتكلم فيه على وحده
الاراضي اليمنيه احنا عندنا الحراك
الجنوبي وثيق الصله بال اماراتيين والحراك
الجنوبي ب يدعو الى انفصال الجنوب عن
الشمال
انه ال اه حزب الاصلاح او جماعه الاصلاح
الاخوان المسلمين في اليمن المفروض انها
جزء من القوى الشرعيه اللي هي بتدعم
الرئيس هادي ذلك الاماراتيين بيستهدف وها
في اطار حملتهم الاستهداف هو اللي جماعات
الاسلام السياسي في اليمن او خارج اليمن
اذن احنا عندنا القوتين الاساسيتين ليسوا
ليسوا على قلب رجل واحد عندنا
الاستراتيجيه اللي موجوده العسكريه خصوصا
في الشمال بتشبه ما يفعله الروس في سوريا
الروس يعتمدوا على عمليات قويه من اعلى من
السماء وقوات بريه تقوم بها الحرس الثوري
يعني قوات ايرانيه وحزب الله
طبعا الجيش السوري على في حاله اليمن
السعوديين ب يكتفوا بالقصف الجوي من
طائراتهم ومقاتلتهم اعتمادا على وجود قوات
تسميها بقه الجيش اليمني تسميها اه قوات
متحالفه مع الشرعيه يسميها بعض ال الشركات
الامن والمرتزقه اللي هما بيشتغلوا لصالح
ال
يعني الشرعيه كل ده موجود على الارض لكن
الواضح جدا على مدار ال حوالي السنوات
الخمس الماضيه ان كثير من مكونات هذه
القوات مستفيده من استمرار الحرب
باعتبارها مورد رزق وليس لحسم الصراع
وبالتالي ف يعني الحرب المستمره لائحه
حريص من هذه القوات على حسمها كما دفع
الجيوش النظاميه حين ان تخوض الحرب الامر
الثالث هو انه الاندهاش من عدم قدره ال اه
السعوديه والامارات او التحالف على حسم
الحرب الحقيقه ب يوحي وكان في امكانيات
الدولتين العسكريه هو واقع الامر مش حاجه
غريبه يعني ليست سابقه يعني على مدار
سبعين سنه اللي فاتت احنا شوفنا امثله
كثيره لدول كبيره عجزت عن حسب سرعتها داخل
يعني امام قوى اضعف كثيرا وعشان كده بتعجب
اما بجد انه بعض الامريكان في صحفهم
ومراكز ابحاث هم بيتكلموا الاستعلاء على
قدرات السعوديين في حسم المعركه ما يعني
الامريكان قادرين واقع الامر ان الامن كان
عجزوا في اكثر من مثال عن حسب صراعات
مشابهه رغم ال التفوق الكاسح عسكريا وفي
الامكانيات عجزوا عن هذا في المثل انا قلت
وفي حرب فيتنام و عجزوا في الصومال وعدوا
في افغانستان وعجزوا في العراق والامثله
كثيره وبالتالي مش غريب اوي نتيجه طبيعه
الحروب اللي من هذا النوع انه تعجز او تظل
جيش متفوق عاجزه عن حسم الصراع هذه القصه
يطول شرحه لكن في النهايه احنا وصلنا الى
ستيل بيت حرب
لا يمكن اي من الطرفين فوز فيها وبالتالي
انا بالظهور يعني حربه لا لا بل لا
الامريكي السعوديين ولا تحالف ادري حسابات
ولا الحوثيين طبعا هي يقدروا حسموها
وبالتالي هذا الحرب المفتوحه الى ما شاء
الله لما تتوقف لما بتوصل القدره العسكريه
او قطاع غزه القدره العسكريه عن حسم
الصراعات يبقى نرجع للمفاوضات والحل
السياسي لكن الحقيقه ان الحل السياسي ايضا
صعبه الحل السياسي دائما ان الاطراف
وتتفاوت تبدا عمليه عمليه سياسيه في
محاوله للاقرار تقريبا بهذا النظر صعب
الاكثر منزله السبب الاول ان ي ان
السعوديه تقعد مع امين او الاتحاد مع مين
هم كانوا رافضين من البدايه هو مش انه
الحرب لتقديم الحوفيين
ومنع نفوذهم او السيطره على تمدد هم في
الامارات اي بلوس على المفاوضات الان
السعوديين والاماراتيين يضطروا للجلوس مع
الحرفيين اللي هما بالاساس كان ورافضين اه
قبول وجودهم كقوه رئيسيه في اليمن الغريب
ان الحوثيين كانوا في مؤتمر الحوار الوطني
اللي تعمل في اليمن 2014 م مثلا ب حوالي
سته في المائه الان بعد هذه الحرب اصبحوا
قبل قوه رئيسيه في اليمن اللي لا تستطيع
ان تتجاهل الا في ميدان المعركه ولا على
مائده المفاوضات الامر التالي انه لان
السعوديه مصر ان الحوثيين هم مجرد وكيل
ايران وهو ما تذكره ايران ويمكن الحرفيون
اذا صدقنا الروايه السعوديه
يبقى معنا حتى الوكالات السعوديون على
مائده المفاوضات وتوقفها عن القتال هذا لن
يكتب لانه في الحاله دي حيكون موافقه
الحوثيين على بدء عمليه سياسيه مرهون
بالاراده الايرانيه وقراره الايرانيين
مرتبطه بتسويه اقليميه كامله ل اه مجمل
يعني اوضاع الازمه الايرانيه في المنطقه
والتسويه الايرانيه مش مساله حينه ولن تحل
لبكره ولا غدا والمساله يعني اه مفتوحه
الامر الثالث انه لا توجد اراده دوليه
يعني مثلا على العكس الوضع في سوريا في
سوريا في اطراف دوليه يعني اه اه فاعله
جدا في المشهد زي مثلا الروس في تركيا
الرئاسي الروسي في اه سوريا لكن في حاله
اه ال اليمن احنا عندنا مفيش اطراف اه
دوليه
والحقيقه انها متروكه تماما الاطراف
الاقليميه والاطراف الدوليه بمعنى
الولايات المتحده او الاتحاد الاوروبي او
روسيا الحقيقه هم يعني اه يعني ايديهم من
المساله وربما يكون مستفيدين من استمرار
الصراع لانه الحقيقه على ارض الواقع انه
شركات الاسلحه في هذه الدول حققت عشرات
المليارات من الدولارات نتيجه عمليات
العقود السلاح اللي بتشتريها السعوديه
والامارات وكمان نتيجه شركات الامن
والمرتزقه اللي بتعمل في الصراع اليمني
الان وكانت هارتز الاسرائيليه كما قال
طويل ب دوليا طرف شركات الاسرائيليه
تستفيد من الصراع اللي هناك ولا لا تستفيد
في شركات امن وشركات تسليح
قدام اه يعني ما فيش عامل من عوامل ال
ال ال ال ال ممكن يساعد فيه انه ممكن نبدا
عمليه سياسيه وبالتالي اه تبدا مسار سياسي
لتسويه القضيه لكن الاخطر من كل لنا اولا
هو التسويه او بدات تبدا مع مين يعني احنا
بدانا الحرب اللي ب مسارين رئيسيين او ب
بحرب الطرفين الرئيسيين في حال وفي مواجهه
الحوثيين التحالف السعوديه والامارات
وباقي الدول العربيه والمدعوم دوليه امام
الحوثيين المدعومين من ايران كما تقول
المملكه العربيه السعوديه الان احنا مش
عدم سرعه واحد احنا قدام ممنوعه من السرعه
يعني قدام الصراع الرئيسي اللي هو التحالف
في مواجهه الحوثيين لكن الان ايضا هناك
صراع مناطق ما بين الجنوب والشمال لان
الحراك الجنوبي والقوى الراغبه في
الانفصال عن الشمال اصبحت اقوى من اي وقت
مضى طيب الاخطر من كده انه لو سلمنا اكثر
من اي وقت مضى منذ سنه الف وتسعمائه
واربعه وتسعين
ان ما حصل الاتحاد او الدم او توحيد اليمن
بين الشمال والجنوب
الاخطر من كده انا كنت بتكلم بعد الدكتور
احمد يوسف الن راجل المتابعه خبير في
الشؤون اليمنيه والاخطر من هذا نحنا الان
في الجنوب امام انفصاليين في المواجهه
الانفصاليين يعني مش الحراك الجنوبي بس
اللي عايز ينفصل بجنوب اليمن عن الشمال
نحنا قدمنا مجموعه من القوى الاخرى اللي
عاوزه
تنفصل عن الجنوب وتبقى كيانات صغيره ما
يعيد اليمن الجنوبي ليس الى حدود ما قبل
اه الف وتسعمائه واربعه وتسعين قبل توحيد
اليمن ولكن الى اليمن الجنوبي قبل
الاستقلال عن بريطانيا ست سبعه وستين لما
كان فيه اكثر من عشرين مشيخه وسلطنه
احنا كمان عندنا حرب على اساس طائفي ما
بين سنه وشيعه يعني عدد كبير من القوى
السلفيه اللي بت حارب اللي مشتركه في
الحرب وتحارب الحوثيين مش بيعتبر هم فصيل
من ا وفصيل متمرد على الشرعيه يتحر
باعتباره القوى الشيعيه في مواجهه قوى
سنيه ويجب احتواء الخطر الشيعي موجود ونحن
امام صراع القاعده ضد الدوله الحقيقه انه
الحرب في اصبحت
تقول او حرب الجميع ضد الجميع في اراضي
التحالف مفتوحه ومتعدده لكنها مرتبطه بعده
امور مبدئيه منها توصيف طبيعه الخصم اللي
هي او العدو اللي بت حرب وا في اليمن
الحوثيين قوي يمنيه مناوئه ليهم واللي هي
مجرد وكيل لايران الاختلاف في التوصيف
يؤدي الى اختلاف الحلول الامر الثاني
طبيعه الاهداف الحقيقيه للتحالف محتاجه من
حلقه ثانيه ان شاء الله لكن المؤكد حتى
الان ان ما يجري يصب في صالح ايران يصب في
صالح دول غربيه وشركات سلاح ومرتزقه لكنه
لا يصب في صالح التحالف والاهم انه لا يصب
ويستنزف طبعا يستنزف كل الاطراف لكنه ايضا
والاهم لا يصب في صالح الشعب اليمني
اشكركم والى لقاء اخر ان شاء الله
[موسيقى]